[Música]
[Aplausos]
del miedo al éxito es el proceso que vi
como artista extremo y para poder hacer
mi trabajo con quién me tengo que mirar
con el miedo es una persona normal o
casi
con una vida normal
pero me gusta mi trabajo a mí no me
gusta no soy adicto a la adrenalina a mí
no me vengan con montañas rusas ni con
paracaídas ni siquiera manejar rápido el
carro
soy feliz con lo que hago
se puede mirar al miedo de frente nunca
lo de la espalda pues mirarlo y sumarlo
como socio en este momento acá tengo el
miedo tengo miedo es verdad pero tengo
acá el mío una tiene alerta me mantiene
enfocado pero mantiene seguro
cuando miramos al miedo de frente
podemos hablar cosas extraordinarias
yo y acá
bueno a ver de qué se trata mi trabajo y
lo peligroso qué es
el equipo de TDX Puravida va a invitar
alguien del público le voy a invitar a
mi círculo rojo extremo así que por
favor tráigamelo alguien y mientras
tanto le voy a mostrar que íbamos a
hacer
vamos a hacer una ruleta rusa algo
sumamente peligroso donde si sale mal
pues será perder alguna de mis manos
tengo un vaso
tengo un segundo vaso y tengo un tercer
vas a pase de la plaza si quitado el
nervio que tiene por favor
pasta no tengo miedo no voy a morder a
caca
mucho gusto como tu nombre Alejandra
cómo te va estamos echando el público
mientras que tenga unos vasos estoy muy
nerviosa tranquila con mis manos la que
van a depender de ti porque son las
representantes del público necesito que
hagas todo lo que te pido también uno
dos tres vasos play 1 cuartos que se
especializa es porque no es lo que es
sino lo que hay debajo un cuchillo 20 cm
míralo de verdad
lo ve la cámara y te cuchillo podré ser
el cambio de mi mano porque si sale mal
mira lo que puede pasar pasa de lado a
lado
simple fácil vuelva a ser tu trabajo el
primer trabajo mezclan los vasos por
favor mézclalo mezcla de mezcla mezcla
mezclas mezclas taca taca taca taca taca
taca taca taca taca perfect
lo voy a poner en su posición
1234 ahora te voy a pedir por favor que
cierre los ojos no mires porque voy a
mezclar pero mírale qué forma siempre
sosteniendo las bases porque después te
va a tocar agosto no toques los vasos si
no vamos a empezar a mezclar de esta
forma así así sabes los ojitos porque no
quiero que sepa donde esté cuchillo
maldito cerramos cerramos cerramos
cerramos el cronómetro un poquito así
ahora lo que quiero que el público
que está acá no sepa dónde está este
cuchillo que vas a ser fuerte enfrente
de la mesa después del público
tú me apartas y empieza mezclar mezcla
mezcla cerrar los ojos tampoco tiene que
ser nadie en el universo mezclo mezcla
mezcla mezclas mes con nadie nos oye
sabes dónde está este cuchillo que puede
prender si puedo seguir trabajando
mañana o no listos ya está bien mezclado
perfect
aquí hay un cuchillo escondido aquí
abajo bueno sabe dónde está el público
lo sabe y yo tampoco vamos a hacer mal y
si todavía voy a poner una venda cuando
me pongo la venda te vas a poner de
espalda mío y me vas a sostener la
muñeca
y tu trabajo va a ser guiarme porque no
voy a ver
íbamos a pasar la mano por encima y los
vasos y cuando mi hermano está por
debajo del vaso vas a decir vaso porque
como yo no sé dónde vas o quieres decir
pero más vale perfecto comentamos
acércate por mi espalda por protocolo
espalda mío
la cita
yo también
bien piensen no veo absolutamente nada
sostener en la mano
vamos por el primero que tienes que
decir Bilbao s ponme la mano
[Aplausos]
sostenerme la mano porque no sé dónde
está la mesa
la mesa bien muy bien pregunta un vaso
roto en el piso no el resto los vasos
están en el centro de los círculos o
está
más o menos
arreglarlo que no se sepa dónde está
bien queda un círculo vacío
dámelo luego no le guste así no molestan
en la mesa también bien cuántos vasos
quedan
qué tienes que decir basbau sí
pero por qué
te explico tienes miedo no bueno
el miedo está en nosotros no en las
cosas significa que las circunstancias
son los que disparan el miedo
sí y que
mamá no
dramático no para que te salga mal y
dónde estoy
dame el círculo que está en el círculo
que Estefa dámelo bien el resto está
pásame la mano por el resto está en el
medio los vasitos haber acomodan los
bien pásame primera mano sale
haz lo que quieras tanto ahora se lo que
quieras
cree dirigir la primera mano primero
vaso y el otro es un poquito y los vasos
está muy cerca y que me puedo lastimar
mira ahora hay un 50% podría que salga
bien no mal vamos
fíjate que vos tenés miedo y seguramente
la gente del público tiene miedo porque
el miedo es contagioso por eso hay masas
de personas que tienen el mismo miedo
que me qué raro
si
vamos una cosa déjame la no me suelte la
mano por favor
te cambia la mano en el centro entre dos
vasos no te no te muevas eh
UF si pones en Youtube 7 y le salió mal
uno no tengo idea de Don 1
dos
[Aplausos]
aplausos
ahora mucha me preguntan cómo hago para
hacer esto
tengo secretos primeros hace 30 años
hago artes marciales y me permite un
entrenamiento especial detecta de
peligro pero eso no es lo más importante
lo más importante que el miedo es mi
socio me mantiene alerta
y ahora ya lo que vamos a hacer hasta
ahora fue bien el protagonista los
vídeos que grande Lego no pero digo no
vamos a cambiar el rol y la protagonista
vas a hacer voz te invito por favor que
te saque los zapatos las medias ni
mostrar el público presente que tengo
acá
lo acabo de ver ahora es totalmente real
verdadero no hay secreto ninguno es una
técnica que aprendí en la INE y este se
llama faquirismo enseñarte hacer cosas
maravillosas con el cuerpo
lo que viene acá son 50 botellas de este
tamaño que rompí especialmente con
protocolo limpieza para nadie las uso
hoteles que quédate con el círculo rojo
porfa
bueno
tú me lees un poco pero tengo ahí no más
mírame
vas a pensar
está nerviosa
si ya sé que te puede pasar pensar un
miedo y todos todos van a ser ale no
todo van a ser Alex Bueno pensar un
miedo
no unido a la nido que no te deja
avanzar que no te dejas llevar este
proyecto que hoy como hago tengo miedo a
eso necesito el diente ese miedo también
que son los vidrios acá tenemos 50
botellas como le dije esto es real es
una técnica y lo vas a lograr
tú eres el guía y nada más pero no
sagrado
hay un sueño que puede ser sueño de
cualquiera un sueño vaca un sueño eso
quiero y a veces uno intenta rodearlo no
no se rodea
enfrenta y se suma como socio y fíjate
que el miedo después te suda
eso sí te dijeron que no hay que tener
miedo cuántas veces te lo dijeron no
tengas miedo cobarde no tengo el mío es
una emoción que nos acompaña todo el día
de que nos levantamos hacemos a dormir
qué pasaría si nunca tuvimos miedo por
ejemplo pasamos por la por la calle no
miro bien carro total no tengo miedo no
sería muy peligroso lo que hay que
aprender a traerlo a favor
tú miedo tu sueño no puedes brincar
porque muchas veces no podemos brincar
dame la mano se me puse el colvo dame la
mano confía que vas a hacer
acércate un poquito más
bien
se calcula que hay una red unos 5000
piezas de vidrios en 50 botellas más o
menos
lo único que hace desconfiar
en voz quieres hacerlo o querés retirar
quieres hacerlo yo no te obligo me
arruinaría si está charla pero no pasa
nada no sería como en TDX el único que
no pudo terminar su acto eso no lo vas a
hacer bien respira
aplausos
Talita
si vas a poder uno lo único que tienes
es apoyar un pie sobre los libros el que
solo uno para empezar te cuento que
esto nunca me salió mal jamás no haber
bueno en otro país no acá
ha puesto un pie confía
escuchar ruido que hace
el otro
no puedes tus miedos están acá a pues el
segundo al lado yo te sostengo no te
viajar sola
eso ahí va
vamos pues
me alejo un poco mejor protocolo lo que
vas a hacer es mirar sin arrastrar los
pies levantados un pie y levantarse el
otro mirándose el pus ahí suave
levantarlo no los habrás levantado
escuchar los pedazos de vidrios cómo se
rompen abajo tus o quien no se cortó el
dedo lavando una copa imágenes de sin
levantar
soy la protagonista es hoy
ay te voy a dejar sola te dejo sola te
suelto la mano eh
[Aplausos]
y ahora tenemos me toca a mí ya está ya
está te habla bien demasiado bien para
despacito despacito
despacito
toma quieres limpiar un poquito los pies
en está bien sí creo llévate los
zapatitos
música de calcita chacha
por favor Alabama
podría hablar toda la tarde y no tengo
pero puedo andar todo el día o toda la
semana del miedo
pero qué es el éxito bueno éxito que
el éxito quizás para algunos puede ser
será la emisión misión de dólares o
algunas misión de amigos misión de
amantes y sea para otro es 100 o 10
pero el éxito
es un estado no un resultado repito el
éxito es un estado no un resultado el
éxito se está Adri lanina está emoción
esas felicidades a libertad cuando
logras algo que querer
con todo el corazón
en el año 2019 puede cumplir un sueño un
señor de 10 años de trabajo donde se me
cancelo tres o cuatro veces ahí la
puertita
cómo había dicho Alejandra el escape
camisa de fuerza más alto de la historia
a 3000 m altura cabeza se abajo colgado
un globo estático loco total
y fue un éxito pero vale pero peso más
puse dinero
y lo vio no hubo muchas reproducciones
en Youtube no tuvo 510 mi sobrino un
éxito personal fue la alegría
ya ves logrado algo que me costó tanto
tanto tanto y quiero compartir con
ustedes estas imágenes tan especiales
para mí muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
todavía tengo piel de gallina cuando voy
a estas imágenes
recuerden
que cuando hemos salido de frente o
enhebrar cosas extraordinarias cuál es
tu miedo por ese medio que no te deja
avanzar no te deja seguir adelante y CCC
miedo y las sabe para que encuentres tu
lado extraordinario el éxito
éxitos en estado no resultados
éxitos Taga
solo toca buscarlo
tomarlo
y sentirlo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]